يا
الله يا
الله مربع كامل تم
ابادته في منطقه معسكر جباليه ليست مجزره
عاديه انها دفن جماعي لحي سكني باكمله هنا
مخيم جباليا شمال قطاع غزه عشرات الوحدات
السكنيه تحولت الى اكوام من الرمال بفعل
ست قنا اسرائيليه تزن كل واحده منها اكثر
من طن وفق وزاره الداخليه في غزه هجوم
جديد اوقع 400 شهيد وجريح وعشرات
المفقودين بحسب وزاره الصحه في غزه مئات
الج مئات
الشهداء في بيوت امنين في بيوت تم قصفهم
جميعا في بيوت امنين مخيم جباليا هو صاحب
النصيب الاكبر من الخسائر البشريه في هذه
الحرب ففي ثالث ايام العدوان قصفت طائرات
اسرائيليه سوق ترنس بالمخيم بعدد من
القنابل الثقيله فقتلت 50 فلسطينيا معظمهم
اطفال لطالما اصطبغ مخيم جباليا بلون
الدماء في كل الحروب التي شنتها اسرائيل
مساحه المخيم التي اشتق اسمه من بلده
جباليا التاريخيه
لا تزيد عن كيلو متر واحد ويعد اكبر
مخيمات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الثمانيه في
غزه واكثر منطقه مكتظه بالسكان على مستوى
العالم اذ يقدر عدد سكانه باكثر من
120 ال فلسطيني هجروا من قراهم وبلداتهم
في جنوب فلسطين المحتله عام
1948 مخيم تاريخ نضالي يؤلم الاحتلال لذا
يرى كثير من قاطنيه ان اسرائيل تتعمد
النيل منه في كل مناسبه فانتفضت الحجاره
عام
1987 اشتعلت من ازقه مخيم جبالها في اعقاب
حادثه الدعس الشهيره لاربعه عمال
فلسطينيين وقبل هذه الانتفاضه كان المخيم
نواه الخلايا العسكريه الاولى للثوره
الفلسطينيه التي بلغت ذروتها في سبعينيات
القرن الماضي
ثمانينياته